[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
later this morning the nation will
remember those who died in armed
conflicts over the past century
in a moment we'll hear from britain's
top soldier a veteran of afghanistan
iraq and northern ireland on war and the
men and women who keep us safe
yesterday cop 26 drew to a close with an
agreement in glasgow but many developing
countries say that nations which have
grown rich over the past 200 years on
the use of fossil fuels
now want to rob them of the chance to
lift their poorest out of destitution
some island states say that the
timetable agreed amounts to a death
sentence for their nations
the issues could not be more serious and
we have an appropriately weighty panel
today
after gruelling two weeks of
negotiations i'll be speaking to the
president of cop 26 alex sharma to get
his take on the talks
it is of course remembrance day and this
week i spoke to the chief of the defense
staff general sir nick carter as he
prepares to retire from the army after
more than four decades
for labor we'll speak to the party's
leading climate change voice shadow
business and energy secretary ed
miliband
and we'll get an independent analysis of
what has and hasn't been achieved at cop
from oxford's professor of energy policy
and economics sedita helm
the commonwealth secretary general
baroness scotland will tell us what's at
stake for vulnerable commonwealth
nations set to bear the brunt of climate
change
and much of the talk of the last two
weeks has been about coal
so we'll get a view from one of the
world's biggest producing countries with
former australian foreign minister
alexander downer
the nation will fall silent at 11
o'clock today remembering all those who
made the ultimate sacrifice in service
of this country her majesty the queen
will be at the cenotaph to lead the
national remembrance day service
it'll be particularly poignant for
general seneca carter the chief of the
defense staff who will soon retire from
that role and from the british army
which he joined back in 1977
there's been no shortage of major issues
for him to contend with in the last few
years and when i spoke to him at the
royal hospital chelsea i started by
asking about the most pressing
afghanistan and how he felt about the
chaotic withdrawal of western troops
it was tough
it wasn't the outcome that any of us
wanted
and we hoped right up until the end that
the
afghan government and its armed forces
would be able to
hang in there and create the sort of
circumstances in which you could get a
proper political reconciliation so for
all of us it was tough and of course for
those who fought in afghanistan against
the taliban who now are in power that
was particularly difficult because of
course they were the enemy at the time
it must take a lot for soldiers now
having fought in the way that they did
you did in afghanistan
to
have to talk to the taliban
is that what we have to do now
um we certainly have to engage them for
a number of reasons i mean first and
foremost there are still afghans who
worked with us who we are worried will
be the subject of vendettas and we would
like to see them find a way out of
afghanistan and we would like to look
after them to achieve that
secondly we're very worried about the
humanitarian situation in afghanistan
and that's been in the media this week
and in order to resolve that one has to
engage with the taliban government to
try and make sure the money gets to
where it needs to get to
and then i think also
we need to engage with them to get them
to understand that they need to govern
inclusively
because many of the gains that we made
in the 20 years that we were engaged
there we could lose if they don't govern
inclusively and the rights of women the
opportunity for girls to go to school
and the rights of all minorities in
afghanistan need to be properly
respected and if that doesn't happen
then
the answer is that we will have failed
it must be a bitter pill to swallow
though for
not you but someone like you to have to
sit down opposite
both people that you fought against and
also people that frankly
in what they
want to do what they did before when
their government
feels abhorrent
yes but but i think um we've all been
around long enough to know that wars
generally end in a conversation and they
generally end with a compromise
now if afghanistan turns out in five
years time to be a country that is being
governed inclusively in which the rights
of all of its people are properly
respected then i think we can look back
on our intervention in afghanistan with
some satisfaction there's a big if at
the front end of that
and if that means that we have to talk
to people that we originally regarded as
the enemy then so be it it's tough to do
but let's face it that's how we achieve
peace in northern ireland
before they came into government this
time taliban said
we're different
do you really believe that
um i think they have definitely done
some that some things already that are
different
i mean the fact that the media is still
being allowed to operate and to report
relatively honestly in afghanistan is a
good indicator
it is still the case that women are not
in the government and are not going to
secondary education but they are going
to primary education and that is
different to what they did in the past
um so there are things that are going on
in afghanistan which are definitely
different to what they were uh 20 years
ago
and that i think is because
this taliban government should we call
it taliban two rather than taliban one
they recognize that 60 of afghans have
been born since 2001 and that's a very
large proportion of the population
who've seen a slightly different country
to the one that predated 2001 and the
taliban at the end of the day know that
they have got to take people with them
if they're going to govern effectively
they can't govern completely brutally
that just won't work in the modern
environment because the thing that's
really changed is social media and
modern media and they can't put that
back in the box are you in favor of the
kind of inquiry perhaps a public inquiry
into
afghanistan the afghanistan um
exercise well i think we need to be
clear that i think unlike iraq nobody i
think was in any doubt that the reason
for entering afghanistan in the first
place was just there was a unanimous
security council resolution indeed
article 5 of the nato treaty
was placed on the table so i think
anybody's in any doubt that it was a
just war i think there are some big
questions that need to be answered about
how the war was conducted thereafter
and those are lessons that both
policymakers and military figures and
for that matter more broadly the
development community need to learn
whether the right way of achieving that
is through a public inquiry or not i
don't know because i don't think this is
about portioning blame or anything like
that this is about making sure that we
all learn from the experience so that
next time we have to do something like
this we do it better than we did this
time you said that you could imagine
afghanistan being a tourist destination
really
well what i was trying to say is that um
in the great swathe of history you know
nobody would have thought uh in the late
1970s that vietnam would ever be a place
that westerners would go on holiday
you know 50 years downstream vietnam is
an extraordinary successful country the
point i'm trying to make is give
everything time are we in danger of
entering a new cold war with china
no i don't think we are and indeed i
don't think that's the right direction
to travel now i think we everybody
recognizes that um this century is going
to be the asian century and that china
is going to be at the heart of that um
and that there are going to be many
areas where we need to work with china
and indeed engage with china and trade
with china because that's where the
economic value is going to come from
i think we will also
observe that there are things that china
does which we don't approve of uh
china's human rights record the way it's
behaving with the uyghurs and with hong
kong are things that we will absolutely
call them out on what could we possibly
do to defend taiwan
um well there's some big questions there
about whether it's our task to defend
taiwan
and that's not something that i'm going
to opine on because these are political
judgments i mean i think what i would
say as a military officer
is that ultimately we want to make sure
that we don't go to war over issues like
that
because that would not be in anybody's
interests and your advice is it would be
plausible
for the military in whatever
configuration
to defend taiwan against uh chinese
aggression the answer is that i have not
considered it yet um and i think you
know my military advice is always going
to be
to try and avoid going to war the
um former mi6 officer christopher steele
told uh sky news that russian leaders
believe that they're at war with the uk
and its allies that makes sense to you
do you agree with that well
i think that
russia
probably regards the
global strategic context as a continuous
struggle
in which i think they would apply all of
the instruments of national power
to achieve their objectives
but in so doing don't want to bring on a
hot war
so yes i think in a way he's right the
question of course is how you define war
and i would tend as a soldier we're
tending to find war as the actual act of
combat and fighting and i think they
don't want to do that i think they want
to try and achieve their objectives in
rather more nuanced ways let's talk
about the armed services that you are
leaving behind as you retire
are they fit for purpose
um point i guess is is what you think
their purpose is
and if you believe that we're here to
deter war from happening then my
judgment is that
our armed forces
are very much fit for deterring our
enemies of course one has to remember
that we do this in an alliance we do it
in nato nato is the bedrock of our
security and fundamentally we see our
security being delivered through
that european relationship at the heart
of nato and the answer is that we are
very much uh leaders within nato and i'm
pretty confident that we're well
prepared to do what we have to do as
part of that nato alliance the secretary
of state complains that
women are still unlikely to get to the
most senior roles in the armed services
uh
do you agree
and if so
uh i suppose he would be saying this is
a failure on the part of you and your
colleagues
um
yes i mean the facts are clear we do not
have enough women at the top of the
armed forces we have more than we did
have but we don't have enough and
there's a reason for that
and that's because the armed forces are
a bottom fed organization
and if you think
back a few years it was only in 2016
when i was the chief of the general
staff took the decision to open all
roles up to women in the army including
the combat roles and up until that point
you know 60 percent of the roles in the
army were available to women but not all
of them so it was difficult of course
for women to rise up through the ranks
in order to be able to get to the
highest possible ranks
i think we've done a lot to try and
adjust the career structure as well
because the career structure is one that
frankly was designed for men
and we've had to change that and we are
changing it to make it easier for women
if they wish to raise families to take
time out to do that and then to be
promoted based upon their potential
rather than what they do during their
thirties as that's the sort of typical
age that we're talking about
but fundamentally it's also about
culture and what we have to do is to
create a culture in the armed forces
which
looks to maximize everybody's talent and
not to be exclusive in the way it does
it the nature of warfare is changing i
mean is laddishness necessarily part of
modern warfare one might equally argue
geekishness is part of modern warfare
when i talk about there's a difference
between the nature of war which is the
political act it's about combat it's
about fighting and it's about
human interaction in a violent way the
character of warfare is different and
that's where you bring in geekiness
cyber and all these other things i still
believe that it will be necessary for uh
soldiers in the final analysis to have
to go close and personal with each other
in order to achieve an outcome if you
are fighting a genuine war and that is
the nature of war so the answer is that
it will still be necessary to have
people who are prepared to do that a
tenfold increase in reports of rape by
teenagers in the armed forces which
you've yourself said are truly shocking
if if we keep that idea that we have to
have these warriors this type of
warriors is it a consequence of that
that we're going to
have to live with that kind of
i don't even call it behavior
no we're absolutely not going to live
with that sort of behavior because what
we're going to do is to make sure that
our values and standards which are well
understood are properly enforced and
we're absolutely going to make sure that
the leaders in the armed forces
understand those values and standards
and recognize that it is their task on
the one hand to make sure that we are
capable of fighting if we have to fight
but on the other hand that we're capable
of building inclusive teams in which
everybody feels respected a key value
and in which everybody feels that
through being included they are able to
contribute to our ultimate purpose and
that is why
the stories that we're hearing at the
moment in in the media and which have uh
are being properly investigated are
shocking because they are genuinely i
suspect a failure of leadership and they
need to acknowledge that it is perfectly
respectable on the one hand to be able
to fight but on the other hand you need
to do it in a sensible and civilized way
and that matters on the battlefield as
well because if we lose sight of our
values and standards on the battlefield
and if we lose sight of the importance
of the rules of war then we will lose
the moral high ground in relation to our
opponents and that's pretty fundamental
as well we've seen in recent days
allegations and in fact they're pretty
well founded of the behaviour of troops
in
kenya
it's a it's a scandal really isn't it
um the allegations are truly shocking um
and um it's absolutely vital that we get
to the bottom of them as quickly as
possible and that those who are guilty
if they are guilty of those allegations
are brought to trial and we're going to
cooperate very closely with the kenyan
authorities to make sure that
that is resolved as quickly as it
possibly can be there is a sense that
the behavior
of some of our service people
particularly men uh
is it is such that they seem to think
that actually because they play this
incredibly important role they're
allowed to do all sorts of other things
and that has both
that bring the army and the other
services into distribute it also by the
way i imagine discourages women from
joining and wanting to stay in the armed
forces this this is all bad the bottom
line is that you cannot have um the sort
of culture that leads to
this sort of behavior and these sort of
allegations you know it's fundamentally
disgraceful
and in no way
can the armed forces
be happy if that occurs um it will be a
deterrent to all sorts of things that we
espouse and we must get to the bottom of
it
general senec carter there
cop 26 finished late last night and
we're still plowing through the wealth
of detail but the immediate reactions
were mixed to say the least
i'm joined now by labour's shadow
business and energy secretary ed
miliband good morning mr milban morning
two weeks of talking and um some say
that yesterday was a substantial
breakthrough others say cop was a flop
where are you on this
well i would say that after glasgow
trevor 1.5 degrees keeping 1.5 degrees
alive is
frankly in intensive care and it's our
job
in the next 12 months to show that we
can
save it the reason i say that is because
the task of
glasgow the task of the world is to
halve global emissions over the coming
decade that's by 2030 that's what the
scientists tell us is necessary to keep
1.5 degrees alive
and the truth about glasgow despite
some progress
is that the world is only probably about
20 or 25 of the way to that goal so
there is a chasm now
between where we need to be
in halving global emissions
and all major countries have to step up
and play their part in that and where we
are
you've actually said that the developed
countries have a particular
responsibility to those countries which
are still developing
essentially that countries like britain
european countries and so on
have the bigger burden
to play here did yesterday's result
tell you that we fail that we in
developed world have
failed in that
in that responsibility or have we
succeeded
i think we are dragging our feet really
in a very problematic way you know you
know i was part trevor of the 2009
copenhagen uh summit the equivalent of
glasgow's summit yesterday
and at that summit a promise was made to
developing countries which is to
developing in vulnerable countries that
the 100 billion dollars of finance
public and private finance will be
provided to them by the richer world and
this is about an existential crisis that
so many of these and countries are
facing and so many of them talk so
movingly at these talks about the fact
that that their countries will literally
disappear if action is not taken well
the problem is that
more than a decade on this finance has
not been delivered and the key thing
trevor is that there isn't just a moral
reason to do that there is also
frankly a self-interest reason because
the reason that the paris summit of 2015
succeeded in a way perhaps that glasgow
didn't is that an alliance was built of
vulnerable countries on the one hand and
developed countries like ours on the
other
to to drive forward ambition and also
put pressure on big countries like china
to act now now because in the final
hours of this summit
developing countries were still arguing
about whether this hundred billion would
be provided i'm afraid that coalition
wasn't properly formed i just have to
sort of say as i have nothing but praise
for alok sharma at who you're having on
later on and the job he did as
co-president but i'm afraid the rest of
the government didn't help him and
undermined him with decisions like
cutting overseas aid because we were
then saying to other countries please
step up on climate finance when we were
stepping back on aid to poorer countries
well whether the rest of government
helped or not let's just deal with what
happened yesterday had you been sitting
in alok sharma's seat and the indians
and the chinese and
nobody seems to be mentioning the
australians had
turned up and said look this phasing out
cold's got to go let's
have a phrase like phasing down what
would you have done would you have
accepted that or would you have said
i'd rather have no agreement
than this agreement
well look i'm very hesitant to second
guess alot because i think he's done an
amazing job to be honest and i think
he's impressed people around the world
with his diligence and his commitment
and his integrity
i wish that the um chained last minute
change hadn't been made but i wasn't
privy to those discussions i think there
is a wider lesson here though which is
we need to do more to put pressure on
all of the big emitters uh frankly um
that includes india that includes china
it includes countries like australia
trevor you know we're we're doing a
trade deal with australia and we've
agreed to drop the paris temperature
commitments from the the trade deal now
australia is a real lagard on climate
they've got a net zero target to get to
zero emissions in 2050 but it's not
really a proper plan and they've got 20
30 targets that if every country was
doing what they're doing would take us
to four degrees of warming now that
would be catastrophic for the world if
we ended up in that position so i think
part of the lesson of the what you know
what's going to be different in the next
12 months compared to the last 12 months
is that
for all countries the climate policy
can't sit on the side of their other
approaches of their other policies got
to be it's got to be at the heart of
what we do we should be rewriting that
australian trade deal we should be
saying to australia look i'm afraid if
you want to be part of the club of
nations if you want to trade deal with
us then you've got to step up and and
you know i think it's really important
this that we can't leave glasgow glasgow
was modest progress it wasn't the
transformation we needed but we can't
leave glasgow and and if you like step
back the fight
to really keep 1.5 alive starts here in
the run-up to cop27
well this this comes right to the point
doesn't it
what are we prepared to give up to make
this kind of thing happen because china
and india and pretty much everybody else
can say
always
you know you can yell at us as much as
you like but until you do your part
why should we make our citizens suffer
let's just start
the hundred billion that you rightly
referred to
hasn't yet been delivered i mean how how
are the um small
states island states
are supposed to believe anything that we
say when we haven't even fulfilled a
pledge from 12 years ago
i mean you are completely right about
this trevor uh you're completely right
and you know
it's the hundred billion and as i say we
should restore the overseas aid cut look
look we
cutting overseas was the single worst
decision this government made in the run
up to cop because it undermined our
moral authority it meant that when we
were going to the french the germans the
others and saying please step up on
climate finance they were saying well
how can you tell us to step up you're
the only g7 country at jakarta but you
know it's not just about the issue of
100 billion because 100 billion you know
it might surprise your viewers to know
this the 100 billion is in a sense the
starting point for the cost these
countries are going to face but it's
also about things like vaccination you
know it is a scandal that when you look
across the developing world we've got
one or two percent of populations in
some parts of the developing world that
have been vaccinated and i'm afraid we
haven't the boris johnson said at the g7
summit in cornwall that we would
vaccinate the world by the end of 2022
we are way off that this is an issue of
trust too and you know the whole thing
here abroad and at home is that this is
a matter of collective solidarity this
is a matter of whether we are in it
together we're in it together globally
and we're in it together in britain as
well whether we're going to guarantee
that we don't just have ambition in
tackling the climate crisis but we also
have justice and and those two things
are absolutely intimately linked
all right well look i mean i i i hear
what you're saying and you know i feel
your indignation but let's get to the
raw politics of this um the truth is
it's a hard sell
uh for us to do our part uh on this
we have to be talking to our
population about um
new boilers 18 grand
a shot electric cars way more expensive
than anything that anybody gets in
behind the wheel on today uh more
insulation now
is labor going to be saying to the
population look everybody we know this
is going to cause cause us pain but
realistically
we're going to have to bear that pain if
we're going to meet these objectives are
you ready for that
i'll tell you what i'm going to be
saying and what we have said which is we
have set out a pledge to invest 28
billion pounds extra each and every year
between now and 2030 in tackling the
climate crisis and the reason this
matters to your question trevor is we
have to we have to make this fair for
the population we have to make this fair
for citizens so you know the truth is
that the cost of electric cars are
coming down but we should be giving zero
interest loans to people so that lower
and middle income families can afford
electric cars we should be doing more to
help subsidize people in the transition
to new boil to
to zero carbon heating so that it
doesn't cost people more than a new
boiler and and i'll be absolutely
explicit with you trevor i think it is
right to make this investment now it's
right to borrow to make that investment
and here's the thing this is the prudent
and responsible choice because the
normal argument people make against
government borrowing to invest is that
it will store up debts for future
generations the biggest debt we can
store up for future generations is not
tackling this crisis and there is a
fascinating report from the office of
budget responsibility published in july
which says the costs of climate action
delaying by a decade the cost of climate
action action doubles the overall cost
so acting now is the right thing to do
morally it's the right thing to do
economically and it's the right thing to
do to create jobs in our country to
tackle for your body and i'll give you
one very concrete example literally
a national program of home insulation
and retrofit around this country street
by street house by house could cut bills
cut carbon emissions create jobs and
make us less dependent on the on
international gas this makes economic
sense
all right well uh
let's see if there's uh a pledge that
can be made here
um cut emissions by
half by 2030 net zero by 2050 and labor
will do whatever it is whatever is
necessary uh to coin a phrase used by
the current chancellor whatever it takes
to meet the initial outlay for the
consumer and the citizen to meet those
pledges labor will do whatever it takes
we absolutely have to do whatever it
takes you know you know and and actually
we need to go further and faster than
the numbers that you just said and the
reason this this matters is because if
we end up look after glasgow the
scientists tell us that on the base of
the pledges made by countries we're
heading for 2.4 degrees of warming now
that might not that might sound to some
people quite harmless but you know what
it means it means billions more people
facing extreme heat waves
we had terrible floods in doncaster in
my constituency in 2019 and in 2007 it
means more extreme weather events like
that and the other thing is that
this is not i'm not just in the let's
avoid disaster business because actually
by creating by investing we can create
good jobs we can tackle fuel poverty we
can create cleaner air see i think part
of the argument that people like me need
to make this stronger trevor okay you
make the point is is that this is about
creating okay better world and a better
life for people all right well let's
bring the people of doncaster into this
conversation
um
everybody can say we must do this
everybody can be on the side of virtue
but when you say to them on the doorstep
by the way this is going to cost you
thousands of pounds because because we
have to do it
otherwise you know other people will be
underwater we'll have all sorts of
problems
do they say uh in doncaster yes we
understand mr miliband yes here's i'm
i'm going to start saving now or do they
say oh
not sure about that
i think i'm saying something different
to you trevor and i think this is a
difference between our approach and the
government's approach because we're
lucky in this country that both parties
want to tackle this problem but we've
got different ways of doing it i'm
saying to you that government needs to
make the investment so it's financially
possible for people to make yeah but but
government's money doesn't come out of
out of nowhere it comes out of that well
out of the people that vote for you
well i'm saying something quite explicit
to you though i'm saying we borrow now
to make this investment because it will
save money in the long run and it's the
prudent and responsible choice you see i
think the british people are in a very
real event you have to pay it back
i i i think that well yes yes but we'd
have to pay a lot more back if we didn't
act you see i think the british people
are in a very sensible place on this i
think they're saying we want to go green
we want to do the right thing but don't
make this a rich person's luxury make it
possible for us to make this change and
we will come with you and also don't
look both ways don't cut passenger duty
for domestic flights don't do all right
things which suggest you're saying one
thing and doing another
all right just very briefly if i may
every time i've i've asked the question
i'm about to ask you to your colleagues
they've um pre-barricaded
new oil field on the uh stream possibly
in scotland cambo it's called a new
coal uh production facility in cumbria
shortly after yesterday
labour must now say
neither of those should go ahead
you're right neither of them should go
ahead no prevarication clarity we cannot
have the cambo oil field going ahead
because it's the equivalent of 18
coal-fired power stations running for a
year we should not be having a cut the
new coal mining cumbria frankly it looks
like total hypocrisy when we are trying
to persuade other countries to act
you're right trevor this does change
things we do need to show we're going to
act and we need to show that with that
we're not facing both ways as a country
that's been the problem with this
government and we need clarity and
strength when it comes to the climate
emergency
ed miliband that is appreciated thank
you very much indeed thank you thank you
now let's get an independent analysis of
just what's been agreed at glasgow and
whether it will be enough to limit the
catastrophic effects of climate change
professor siddita helm is a professor of
energy policy and economics at oxford
university
last week the uh so i beg your pardon
let me
let me uh
talk to you professor helm before i go
on to anybody else
cop 26
progress or just more to use the cliche
blah blah blah
well it's a bit more of the latter than
the former if the objective at cop26 was
to keep 1.5
degrees alive
it's dead
even if for the first time ever
every country does everything that it
promised to do
we won't
be able to achieve 1.5 and i think it's
important to recognize that after 30
years of cops one after the other
in every single year for the last 30
years we've nevertheless added two parts
per million of carbon to the atmosphere
no breaks no hesitations every year
including even last year during the
lockdowns so if you ask the question is
cop 26 you know the turning point of all
the rhetoric that was trotted out before
um as before or previous cops the answer
is no it tells you this isn't going to
happen and there's a very good reason
for that which is that there is this
illusion that you know climate change is
going to be solved in the uk if only we
do stuff here it's going to be fine
we're going to be world leaders and
we're going to crack it and therefore
not avoid therefore avoid the costs as
ed miliband said of climate change no
the truth is that the future of climate
in this world will be largely determined
in places like china india sub-saharan
africa in the rain forests and so on
and if you look at this summit even in
the voluntary pledges the key players
are not at the table
and the 80
fossil fuels which are the mix of our
energy in the globe now
there's no plan to go from 80 fossil
fuels to north globally indeed that's
starkly absent from the discussions at
glasgow so let's not be so
this solves solves the problem it
certainly doesn't
so what was the point of the last two
weeks you make it sound like it was just
a complete waste of time
no no it's very good that people talk
it's very good that people are educated
about what's going on but it's not good
to believe that these great summits are
the crunch point that's going to turn
the globe that isn't what these things
are about and if we really seriously
want to get in the game of no longer
causing climate change we have to get
the metrics right so it's not whether
you produce steel in britain that counts
as opposed to import it it's that there
is steel in our mix territorial carbon
emissions you can get those down by
closing down the steel industry if
that's what you want to do what matters
is our carbon consumption our carbon
footprint and that's part of trade
that's about carbon border adjustments
that's about carbon pricing all the
stuff that wasn't discussed at cop is
absolutely critical to proper engagement
so you and i can genuinely say we are no
longer causing climate change
let's come back to some of those uh if
you like other factors but just
dealing with what cop itself dealt with
a foreign station or the i think the
slogan now is cash cars uh trees and so
on
um can you make an estimate there are
various numbers flying around but can
you make an estimate uh of
what
temperature rise we're headed for
given the promises that were made
yesterday if they were all fulfilled
where would we be
well the best estimate in the public
domain
is the 1.8 to 2.4 and my guess is it's
much closer to 2.4 than it is to 1.8
and
that is really serious that's a
a dramatic uh change which is going to
happen
in this century and affect all of us um
and when we look at you know how we
affect that which is how we persuade the
developing world not to go down the
route that we've gone down in the
developed world you know the core to
this is well how are we going to help
them do it after all we put most of the
stuff up in the atmosphere what's our
contribution well let's look at what our
contribution is the amount to be spent
private and public on dealing with the
great disaster of the uh destruction of
the rainforests in places especially
like the amazon is less than we wasted
on track and trace in this country
the hundred billion which we've never
lived up to in the past is a bit more
than the annual dividend of saudi aramco
and uh quite small compared with what we
spent in 18 months in this country on
coronavirus these are the sorts of
orders of magnitude which tell you the
difference between the brave words and
what really needs to be done to help
sub-saharan africa india indeed even
china address what is the major source
of future emissions and the major
sources of damage to our rainforests and
so on
i want to come back to what you think
should be done but just
paint a picture for us
of that of the consequences
of that 2.4 degrees that you
uh mentioned a moment ago
well
there are two answers to that question
there's the obvious one which is that a
hotter world is genuinely going to be
bad
for
most countries around the world and
worse for some rather than others
as to the exact effects this assumes
that we know precisely how to model
the world's climate with say two to
three degrees of warming in it and
that's not true
it's very complicated as to how higher
temperatures affect all sorts of things
weather patterns right through to uh the
tundra and so on whether it triggers
dramatic changes like the release of
methane from the arctic so i think the
honest answer is we don't know precisely
but there are no suggestions that it's
going to be a good thing and quite a lot
of suggestions it's going to be a bad
and perhaps very bad thing
let me put an alternative point of view
to the one that you've been putting to
me um
the prime minister says that britain's
well on its way to net zero and we don't
need a hair shirt
to achieve it
wouldn't it be lovely if cake isn't
really was true but you can have all the
smarties and it isn't going to cost you
anything at all
let's be straightforward about this
we're taking a carbon intensive economy
and in uh
14 years we want to get rid of 75
percent of emissions and in 29 years we
want to get rid of virtually all of them
and you tell me oh it's going to cost
you very much
now um in your previous interview with
ed miliband he was careful to say that
the costs
are less
than the cost of not acting that's an
admission there are a lot of costs
and we should be honest you should tell
the truth you know if you've got to take
your boiler out if you've got to change
the way you drive if you've got to
change all that stuff in your carbon
diary every day of the stuff you consume
if you've got to do all that long the
idea that you know we're living beyond
our carbon means we're not paying for
the pollution because suddenly we're
going to pay for the pollution because
and by the way the price is going to be
zero this is nonsense and the way to
think about it is to think what the
carbon price would have to be to hit the
target which by the way would be one of
the most efficient ways of getting there
it's not naught so there are substantive
costs out there there is going to have
to be some change on the demand side in
our lifestyles as well as changes on the
supply side but you know hoping the
technological troops are coming down the
hill rapidly to save the day you know 29
years away is not really long enough for
much technical change
we've got to do it with what we've got
and
235 so what new technology do you think
will be on the system in 235 that's not
on the system today which is going to
make a substantive difference not a lot
okay
professor let me lastly just put um this
this to you
uh
it's all very well
uh politicians would say
for the professor of this that and the
other at oxford university to describe
the perfect scenario and tell us we've
got it all wrong but you don't have to
sell this to voters who are going to
have to pay
this is unrealistic politically isn't it
yeah
i completely agree with you right and
what that tells you is it's not that our
politicians are become some kind of
villain of the police piece it's not
that politicians don't understand the
nature of this problem they do the point
is that you and me the public don't want
to pay the cost so if you ask the public
would you like to do something about
climate change they get it that's and
glasgow's really helped in that process
to really understand this is a really
serious problem uh no doubt about it the
opinion polls show that if you ask them
would you like to pay or would you like
cheaper regional air flights um or or
would you like um uh you know to have
airports further subsidized would you
like not to pay extra fuel duty
that's awesome
what it tells you is okay why climate
change is so hard to crack
is that actually we and it's ultimately
you and me that consume this stuff the
polluters don't actually want to pay
and you know that's a nasty political
reality which has to be confronted but
just simply giving people what they want
and telling them that they can have
cake-ism
that isn't leadership that doesn't help
this is a really serious problem and we
need to get on
professor helm thank you very much
indeed
thank you
okay last week the commonwealth
secretary general warned cop 26 in
glasgow that if we lose vulnerable
nations who have battled with courage
and resilience we lose the fight against
climate change she warned that if the
gaps on emissions were not closed and
more money was not made available then
many nations risked being subsumed by
rising sea levels and she urged everyone
at cobb to dig deeper and come together
let's find out if she believes everyone
has dug deep enough and i'm now joined
by baroness patricia scotland
um the union secretary general said that
the collective political will isn't
enough to overcome some deep
contradictions and our fragile planet is
hanging by a thread we're knocking on
the door climate catastrophe
was what was agreed yesterday good
enough for
the commonwealth and particularly the
small islands within it
i think it wasn't good enough but it was
part of the way i mean antonio guterres
was absolutely right we are at code red
and it is deeply worrying that we have
to deep dig even deeper
the truth is that we are now at 1.1
and if you look at the devastation that
that is causing to many of us we've seen
the effects here in the united kingdom
but look at what's happening to the
small and the vulnerable member states
in our commonwealth we have 32 small
states 25 of them are island states and
many of them are facing this existential
threat now
at
1.1 degrees if you look at what's
happened in sub-saharan africa we have
had double the number of
droughts floods what does that mean that
means that there are 45 million more
people in southern africa who are
vulnerable to food insecurity that we
have had 45.6
of those who would have had
better food now have substandard food
these are terrible realities the um
representative from the maldives in a
sense reflected some of this
and said that
yesterday's uh decision reflect
really was a death sentence for them i
mean
how could it possibly be acceptable in
that situation well i think it's it's
not acceptable but let's think about
what has happened because you know you
know i'm very much a
a cup half full person so what happened
in glasgow number one
we are all agree that 1.5 is the
aspirational target no one is saying
that the science isn't pointing in that
direction for the first time we have not
only governments and local governments
but we've got business and the
scientists and all of us
pointing in the right direction we have
an agreement on methane we have an
agreement that we have to do a lot more
on deforestation we have got an
agreement in relation to how much money
is needed but what has not happened
we haven't got the mechanisms of how to
do it secretary would you just hold that
for a moment we have
some breaking news uh
the queen
has decided it's been announced this
morning that with regret she will not be
attending the remembrance
sunday
uh
ceremonies this morning that is breaking
news that is just coming and we're now
going to talk to rhiannon mills our
royal correspondent who i think is in
whitehall right now
that's right of course there was a huge
amount of anticipation about whether or
not her majesty would be here for a
remembrance sunday on thursday we were
told that she would be attending however
in the last few moments we have had a
statement from buckingham palace
confirming that unfortunately her
majesty will not
be attending the cenotaph today now i
can read you the statement that they've
sent through
which says the queen having sprained her
back has decided this morning with great
regret that she'll not be able to attend
today's remembrance sunday service at
the cenotaph her majesty is disappointed
that she'll miss the service so i think
one thing to point out there is they're
saying that she has sprained her back
also i understand that the back's brain
is unrelated to the recent doctor's
advice that we know that she's had over
the last couple of weeks to rest
it is obviously really unfortunate
timing but this back sprain has happened
very recently and we're also told that
nobody regrets the fact that the queen
can't be here
more than the queen herself she is
deeply disappointed not least because
she regards today as one of the most
significant engagements
of the year and of course that is
because she is a member of that wartime
generation during the second world war
she saw her father rallying
the nation as king and also of course
her husband prince philip who died
earlier this year
served during the second world war uh as
well um just to
stress though we are hearing that
because of a back sprain the queen will
not be able to attend
the events here today however other
members of her family will still be here
in force in attendance of course in
recent years the queen has handed over
that responsibility of placing a wreath
at the base of the cenotaph on behalf
the nation she's handed that
responsibility to her son and heir the
prince of wales he will again uh carry
out that duty but just to stress we will
not see the queen here at the center
half today
rhiannon thank you very much indeed for
that announcement uh that the queen will
not be
at the
remembrance day uh ceremonies this
morning um baron of scotland the
commonwealth plays uh a major role in
today's event yourself i think
lay a wreath it will be
um disappointing i think for many of the
veterans absolutely the queen is adored
rightly she has shown total commitment
uh to the commonwealth and that she is
much loved so an opportunity like this
to see her and to pay homage for what
she herself also did because people do
forget that she was an engineer she was
on she was making her contribution as
well so i think there'll be a lot of
sadness but everyone will be wishing her
well everyone will want to see her again
and she is the beating heart of most of
the love that is in the commonwealth so
we do wish her well well i hope that uh
this is just a this is something
temporary it sounds as though it is
precautionary but we will no doubt be
hearing more now um let us return if we
may to the
issues that arose out of yesterday
part of your role uh as
the uh
head of the commonwealth uh secretariat
is to
essentially bring all the members of the
secretary together um
is part of your job of the next year
going to be frankly to stop some of your
members india australia for example
drowning others for example caribbean
islands well the most important thing to
remember and the great thing about our
commonwealth is we all sit around the
same table and i know that both um all
of our members care desperately about
the small states we're going to have the
next commonwealth
heads of government meeting in kigali
next year climate change is bound to be
at the top of the agenda it's really
important for us to remember trevor that
it was the commonwealth back in 1989
way before cop was ever invented that
said that if we did not address this
matter it would be an existential threat
and the commonwealth is so tired of
being right we want no longer to be
right we want to be able to deliver that
1.5 and i do know that both with india
and australia there is a love and
affection and an appreciation of the
small states and when you sit around
that table eyeball to eyeball it's a
very different uh occasion and i think
the only place where that actually
happens is round the commonwealth table
and we will be urging encouraging and
depending on our member states to do
what they've always done and that's to
stand in solidarity it's important to
remember that in malta when our leaders
came together
just days before the paris agenda we
came up the commonwealth came up with
two degrees implementation and a 1.5
aspirational target we will be pushing
and pushing hard and i know that our
small states who are literally seeing
this as a death sentence will not go
give up because if they do they'll no
longer be here and we're not willing for
that to happen we will fight secretary
general thank you very much for your
time this morning i hope we'll return to
this uh in months to come thank you
last night after a gruelling two weeks
alok sharma president of cop 26 appeared
close to tears as he apologized to
delegates that the final text of the
agreement was imperfect his word but he
later insisted that there was consensus
and support for the glasgow deal
for his overall take on this historic
summit i'm now joined live from glasgow
by mr sharma
good morning
can we just first start with that
breaking news from uh whitehall that the
queen
will not be joining the ceremonies this
morning
i imagine that that will be
a matter of some disappointment to you
and other members of government
well look uh obviously i'm very sorry to
hear that but uh i'm just got the news
at the same time as you as i understand
this is precautionary and of course we
wish her majesty all the very best
we um
of course uh witnessed uh the emotional
ending of uh cop 26 uh yesterday evening
and um
much of that was focused on
you was the
uh your reaction exhaustion
uh after two weeks or just or
disappointment at the last minute change
from phasing out coal to facing down
coal
well trevor you know when we started
this whole process two years ago we said
that what we wanted to achieve at
glasgow was to keep within reach uh the
temperature goal of limiting temperature
rises to 1.5 degrees we delivered on
that
there were very many people who doubted
it we delivered on it and actually that
was acknowledged by some of the most
climate vulnerable countries by some of
the climate ngos as well and i'm very
pleased about that not only that but we
also closed off all the outstanding
elements of the paris rule book the
paris agreement after six years it had
not been completed we did that here that
is historic and we also ensured that
there was more money coming to support
developing nations and therefore i think
what we've achieved here is something
really quite remarkable now on the issue
of of coal i should point out trevor
that for the very first time in any of
these conferences the word coal is
actually reflected in the text that
again is a first yes of course i would
have liked to ensure that we maintained
the phase out and rather than the
changing the wording to phase down but
you know on the way to phasing out
you've got to phase down but ultimately
of course what we need to ensure is that
uh we continue to work on this on this
deal on the commitments and on the on
the issue of coal china and india of
course are going to have to justify to
some of the most climate vulnerable
countries what happened you heard that
disappointment on the floor so what i
would say to you that you know overall
this is a historic agreement we can be
really really proud of it but of course
this is just a start we now need to
deliver on the commitments
i i fully understand uh your feelings
about the achievements but um let me
just ask you
personally what are your feelings this
morning towards the countries who
insisted
on that last minute change from phasing
out to phasing down we're talking india
china i imagine australia was somewhere
in the mix
well look i mean i think on the floor
that you heard interventions from china
and india uh
at the end of the day my job was to
build consensus that's what i did i
ensured that before we actually went
back to the podium i had checked
with the negotiating groups or some of
the most climate vulnerable countries
that they could accept the language and
of course they reluctantly did so
because overall this is really a very
good and historic deal but as i said at
the end of the day china and india are
going to have to justify themselves to
these climate vulnerable nations
but you know what uh some of those
developing countries are
feeling this morning
uh bitterness
and the sense that the big polluters the
usa china india australia
got what they wanted and that they are
going home empty-handed and some of them
to tell their people that they better
prepare themselves
to evacuate
or have their countries extinct
well trevor what you heard from the
floor yesterday was first appreciation
of what the uk has done but also
acknowledgement that this deal does
indeed keep 1.5 within reach uh and i
can tell you i've had lots of messages
uh since last night from ministers in
many of those countries thanking us for
what the uk has done uh for the fact
that we've managed to close off the
paris rule book for the fact that there
is more money on the table to support
them as i said this is the start we've
got one year of our presidency we need
to make it count and that means that we
need to hold countries to account for
the commitments that they've made and
those commitments have to be translated
into action and for the very first time
trevor in this deal what we have got is
an agreement that next year countries
are going to have to come back and look
at their 2030 commitments
we've got for the very first time an
agreement that every year ministers at a
high level are going to meet to discuss
this issue and not only that but there
is going to be a report every year on
how we are doing the tracking of these
commitments on on reducing emissions
those are all historic firsts but as i
said we need to now ensure that those
commitments are delivered upon
you you know as well as i do though that
there is deep skepticism
the
big countries promised a hundred billion
for adaptation
12
years ago
it still hasn't been delivered
how will those countries how those
countries expected to believe these
commitments if
that commitment from way back then
hasn't even been fulfilled
now
well look trevor uh you know i've been
to many of the climate vulnerable
countries over the last year and i
completely understand uh their their
sense of frustration uh you know if
you're living on the front line of
climate change and literally on a
day-to-day basis you're being faced with
that of course you're frustrated but as
part of this process one of the things
that we did do i asked other ministerial
colleagues and other governments to pull
together a delivery plan we know with
confidence that that 100 billion will
come in 2023 it may come earlier
and that over that five-year period from
2021 to 2025 we will have a 500 billion
plus to support developing countries
that is appreciated you talked about
adaptation well i can tell you that in
this text it makes it very clear that uh
there's going to be a doubling of
adaptation finance to support countries
by 2025. so we have made progress and
countries do acknowledge that but of
course there is always more to do this
is a 26th cop there will be another cop
this is a process but in this case i
think we can say with some justification
what we've achieved here is absolutely
historic
you said that um the pulse a one 1.5 is
alive but the pulse is pretty weak
what is going to convince you between
now and next year in egypt that those
who are responsible
for
most emissions and most pollution are
really taking this seriously and they
haven't just kicked the can down the
road
well i think we will have to track the
commitments that each of these countries
have made and we've had some historic
commitments you know we've got uh 130
countries coming together to ensure that
by 2030 we're reversing uh deforestation
i mean that's covering 90 percent of the
forests in the world
we've got uh historic agreements on on
coal as well
no more international co-financing from
any of the g20 nations there is a lot
that has been agreed but you're
absolutely right we need to make sure
those commitments are being delivered
upon as i said in this text we have also
agreed that next year countries will
come back and we will have a look at how
they're doing in their 2030 emission
reduction targets that's a historic
first
mr chairman i'd love to carry on talking
to you about there's so much to discuss
but as you know there is breaking news
which we have to address so
for this morning thank you very much
indeed for your time